I've just done a quick easy thing for
you to finding intercepts okay I know it
looks like it'll be awful but actually
because this is already factorize for
you it's really nice because to work out
intercepts you just want one of the
factors to be zero so when it's sine
equal to zero answer zero PI to PI okay
and in the same way when it's cosine
zero and so I plan to do plan to so all
five of those are going to be into sense
okay so far so good now when you're
working out the derivative sorry when
you working out the stationary points
again you want by the factors to be zero
okay so here's where my working has
taken me and you determined from here um
this part here sine squared X is equal
to zero right that means I want sine to
be zero okay which in fact I've already
saw zero PI to PI now by the way that
means that we've got intercepts and
stationary points at the same position
hmm what would that mean we think about
it for second okay
all right next we have to solve this
okay so I just rearranged a little bit
you're gonna get sine squared squared is
equal to three on four okay
so therefore watch out for the plus
minus because I've taken the square root
of both sides so this is plus or minus
on to okay now the plus or minus things
would be make it worse right but
actually it makes it better because it
just means you've got answers in all of
the quadrants okay so this worked out
the station for to go from this already
he's gone that's a white a leash I think
this is this is route 302 so that base
angle is 60 degrees if you like just
apply on three then you should also have
PI minus PI on three they should have PI
plus PI over three and then you should
have two pi minus PI over three
I'll graph it for you okay so here we go
here's my intercepts 0 PI to PI prime to
3 Prime 3 in between ok now if that's PI
on - where's pine 3 going to be which is
a stationary point just a little bit to
the left
right it's the left look halfway because
that'd be pylon for ok so I've got a
stationary point for spatial point of
the arcs extra point yup NPR no sorry
not open just 0 not that one and 2 pi ok
now when you go in you take these X days
and you sub them back in to the Y values
okay you're gonna get I think 3 root 3
on the 16 that's right you get plus or
minus 2 root 3 on 16 depending on which
stationary point you get so I think this
one goes up first that's right so are we
gonna kill again this is PI on 3 3 root
3
on 16 this is gonna be a max ok so I'm
gonna kind of come up and I'm gonna go
back down ok and then you get the same
kind of thing happening this is going to
be the opposite shape but you've got to
come up to a stationary point so I had
to knit miss you I'm in a bit of a hurry
that's your shape and it repeats
that's periodic so there's my station
important sorry that should it's
stationary point there that's try that
stationary point down stationary point
and the cross okay that's a messy had
more time I make it beautiful
but there's your five stationary points
and your sorry seven stationary points
and five intercepts thanks